cinco días después de la toma de kabul
por parte del grupo talibán persiste el
caos en el aeropuerto de la capital
afgana con miles de civiles que intentan
escapar del país y el presidente de
estados unidos joe biden prometió usar
todos los recursos para evacuar a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses ya los
aliados de afganistán
la canciller de alemania angela merkel y
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin se
reunieron en moscú merkel pidió la
liberación del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni y abordaron temas como la
situación en afganistán la inestabilidad
en ucrania entre otros
y en haití continúa la evacuación de
heridos en las zonas más afectadas por
el terremoto que hace seis días sacudió
al país y que deja al momento más de
2.000 muertos las operaciones se
complican por los daños en las
carreteras pero también por el control
territorial de las pandillas
[Música]
hola muy buenas noches bienvenidos una
vez más a las noticias de france 24
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos como
cada día y santiago ariztía y comenzamos
esta emisión con información sobre
afganistán y es que cinco días después
de la toma de kabul por parte del grupo
talibán persiste el caos en el
aeropuerto de la capital del país con
miles de personas que están intentando
escapar de la nación y el presidente de
eeuu joe biden aseguró que pondrá todos
sus recursos al servicio de las
evacuaciones veamos el informe we would
you os devolveremos a casa es el mensaje
del presidente de eeuu joe biden a dos
estadounidenses y colaboradores afganos
que siguen atrapados en afganistán
decenas de miles de personas deben ser
evacuadas antes del 31 de agosto fecha
marcada para la retirada de tropas
y esta es una de las evacuaciones aéreas
más grandes y difíciles de la historia y
el único país del mundo capaz de
proyectar tanto poder en el otro extremo
del mundo con este grado de precisión es
eeuu de américa
evacuaciones pero también mucha espera
así estuvo durante todo el viernes el
aeropuerto de kabul la desesperación
aumenta después del informe de la onu
que advertía de la búsqueda del talibán
de ciudadanos que hayan colaborado con
fuerzas extranjeras
mientras la premio nobel de la paz
afgana malalai usarse y mostró
preocupación por el futuro de las
mujeres de afganistán
tenemos miedo de que nos vuelvan a
privar de nuestros derechos estoy
preocupada por mis hermanas afganas y
espero que no se les arrebate su
libertad la rutina regresa a la ciudad
de edad con la tradicional oración del
viernes y el talibán muestra dos caras
una más abierta con milicianos
haciéndose autorretratos en lugares
turísticos pero también la del terror
como estos combatientes armados en la
ciudad de qalat rusia y china- están
mostrando una apertura más diplomática
al talibán
no podemos dejar de lado la realidad son
autoridades de facto no hay alternativa
a los talibanes
ante estos miles de afganos tratan de
cruzar la frontera con pakistán serían
10.000 personas según la ong italiana
emergency y en medio de este avance de
talibán en afganistán en turquía cientos
de mujeres manifestaron su apoyo a las
afganas en la calles de estambul donde
además exigieron a las autoridades de su
país que no reconozcan a los insurgentes
aunque los talibanes se declaran más
moderados que hace 20 años y prometen
respetar los derechos de las mujeres
ciertas restricciones y conductas hacen
pensar lo contrario
mujeres cubiertas de pies a cabeza
escuelas quemadas y todo tipo de
vejámenes escenas vividas día a día
cuando el talibán gobernó afganistán
entre
1996 y 2001
durante este periodo las violaciones de
derechos humanos básicos fueron
constantes ninguna mujer podía trabajar
ni estudiar y muchas vivían en
confinamiento forzado ya que no podían
salir de sus hogares sin la compañía de
un hombre nuestro principal objetivo es
establecer la ley islámica es lo único y
lo mejor para el país nada más importa
veinte años después el regreso al poder
de los talibanes tras una ofensiva
relámpago preocupa a los ciudadanos en
especial a ellas sin embargo los líderes
prometen respetar los derechos de las
mujeres siempre y cuando sea bajo la ley
islámica estamos sujetos a los derechos
de las mujeres que nos ha otorgado la
sharía nuestras hermanas y madres
tendrán todos los derechos que dios les
ha dado las mujeres son parte de la
sociedad las mujeres trabajarán en la
educación la salud y otros campos y
desempeñarán un papel activo y aunque
las niñas bajo estrictas normas de
vestido ya retomaron colegio en herat y
el discurso se escucha más moderado que
antes no convence a todos hay denuncias
de que a diferencia del discurso de sus
jefes en kabul los comandantes talibanes
en algunas regiones están detrás de
quienes hayan cooperado con el gobierno
anterior ya habrían torturado a algunos
y asesinado a otros amnistía
internacional indica que el número de
matanzas podría ser mayor pero que el
talibán ha cortado las redes de
comunicación para prevenir que se
publiquen más imágenes además ordenaron
una lista de mujeres entre 12 y 45 años
para que se casen con sus guerreros
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
sigue preocupada por el riesgo de
violaciones de los derechos humanos
contra la población civil incluidas las
mujeres y las niñas
en medio de la incertidumbre miles
buscan huir del país el gran
interrogante es qué pasará con los y
sobre todo las que se queden bajo el
régimen talibán
en otras noticias el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin y la canciller alemana
angela merkel se reunieron este viernes
antes de la salida del poder de la
funcionaria alemana y en la agenda del
encuentro estuvo la crisis en afganistán
también el pedido de liberación del
opositor ruso alexéi navalni y la
presencia rusa en ucrania entre otros
temas unas flores para su último
encuentro oficial este viernes la
canciller alemana angela merkel y el
presidente ruso vladimir putin se
reunieron en el marco del último viaje
oficial a rusia de la líder alemana
afganistán fue el punto central de la
cumbre bilateral
en nuestra opinión lo más importante
ahora es evitar que todo tipo de
terroristas entren en los territorios de
los países vecinos de afganistán
disfrazados de refugiados
putin añadió que los países no deben
imponer sus valores sobre el país
asiático y que se deben aunar esfuerzos
para no desintegrar al estado mientras
tanto para angela merkel debe haber un
diálogo con el grupo talibán que permita
salvar vidas otro de los temas del
encuentro fue el pedido libertad que
hizo merkel del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni encarcelado por el kremlin
una vez más le pedía al presidente ruso
que libere alexéi navalni y también deje
claro que seguiremos este caso de cerca
el opositor ruso había sido trasladado
en avión a alemania el año pasado
después de ser envenenado justamente hoy
hace un año moscú negó tener cualquier
responsabilidad con el incidente pero el
kremlin y encarceló a nadal y tras su
regreso a ruiz ya el gasoducto nord
stream 2 que transportará gas natural de
rusia alemania también fue tema sobre la
mesa la construcción pasará por ucrania
y sus opositores temen que aumente la
influencia de rusia como proveedor de
energía vital a europa el domingo se
espera que merkel se reúna con el
presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski alemania ha sido un
actor importante de los esfuerzos por
negociar la paz entre ucrania y rusia y
hoy se están cumpliendo seis días desde
que un terremoto de magnitud de 7.2
acudir a haití y el balance en este
momento deja más de 2.000 muertos 12.000
heridos y miles de familias sin sus
hogares la evacuación de los heridos se
complica cada vez más así como también
la llegada de la ayuda humanitaria y hoy
la organización de estados américanos se
comprometió a apoyar a la isla en el
desafío de su reconstrucción veamos el
informe
casi una semana después del terremoto de
haití
el colapso temporal se superpone al
habitual as y evacuan los helicópteros
estadounidenses a los heridos es por
aire la única alternativa de auxilio los
deslizamientos por las tormentas impiden
el acceso por carretera
hay muchos daños en infraestructuras
carreteras hay informes de muchos
heridos veo a muchos médicos yendo y
viniendo algunas comunidades aisladas en
lo alto de las montañas han sido muy
afectadas
esta falta de acceso complica hacer un
balance real de víctimas pero hay otros
factores como el tradicional apego de
los haitianos por sus muertos que hace
que no los quieran abandonar también la
disputa territorial las organizaciones
humanitarias desconfían de las pandillas
estas habían dado una tregua a
principios de semana sin embargo dos
médicos han sido secuestrados provocando
huelgas en algunos hospitales que se
suman a la falta de insumos hay una gran
necesidad de oxígeno en este momento
la demanda en los últimos dos meses
aumentó más del 200 por ciento y ahora
mismo no podemos producir ni vender
oxígeno la escasez y la dificultad
también llegan a las ayudas humanitarias
las cuales no son suficientes para todos
los afectados donde me ido con las manos
vacías porque al llegar a por la ayuda
me dijeron que no estaba incluida en la
lista de la organización
problemas que por desgracia son
costumbre en haití el país más pobre de
américa que vive un nuevo terremoto
después del de 2010 que dejó más de
200.000 fallecidos y un mes después del
asesinato de su presidente joven el mois
de mercenarios más noticias en fra 2004
el diplomático oscar maúrtua prestó
juramento como nuevo ministro de
relaciones exteriores de perú y
reemplaza así el vacío que dejó héctor
béjar que renunció 19 días después de
haber asumido en medio de polémicas
declaraciones sobre el terrorismo que
realizó en el año 2020 maúrtua ya se
había desempeñado en esta cartera a
principios de la década de 2000 bajo el
mandato del presidente centrista
alejandro toledo y su nombramiento es
crucial para el futuro político del
presidente de castilla ya que su
gabinete enfrentará una votación de
confirmación del congreso liderado por
la oposición antes de fin de mes
y los incendios a lo largo de todo el
mundo parecen prolongarse de una manera
indefinida y no dar tregua cuando
francia por ejemplo acaba de anunciar el
fin de los juegos en la región de var
están siendo contenidos pero no apagados
perdón bolivia por su parte y la región
de california en eeuu parecen no poder
ver el fin de sus conflagraciones los
detalles en el siguiente informe
parece no tener fin en francia se
anunció este viernes que los incendios
en la región del bar estaban contenidos
pero no apagados el riesgo es que con el
viento el fuego retomé y queme todo lo
que todavía no se ha quemado después de
cinco días de lucha intensa en la zona
del sur de francia la situación sigue
preocupante la investigación apunta a
unas posibles colillas de cigarrillo
como el origen de las llamas en
california el incendio bautizado dixie
el segundo más grande en la historia del
estado está teniendo hermanos menores en
primer plano está kaldor frente a un
descontrol de la situación las
esperanzas se ponen en el clima
esperando que bajen las temperaturas
estamos agradecidos por el clima
favorable de anoche durante esta
comisión de bandera roja prevemos un
aumento de la actividad de los incendios
a partir de esta tarde a medida que la
capa de inversión en el aire se vaya
quemando and soft más de 650 bomberos
tres helicópteros están movilizados para
contener esta nueva conflagración que
sacude al oriente del estado
si la mayoría de los incendios en el
mundo parecen ser accidentales y
causados por las altas temperaturas
históricas la situación parece diferente
en bolivia donde existe una política de
deforestación masiva para despejar los
campos oyeron imágenes de los males
pegadores hasta ahora del mundo en un
acto muy triste pero es real no entonces
bolivia actualmente le da más valor a un
bosque de nuevas bosque o sea la tierra
sin árboles que a un bosque en el total
son más de 200 mil hectáreas de bosques
y tierras cultivables que se volvieron
humo en bolivia las autoridades temen
que se queme por completo la reserva
natural de ñemby guasu en la frontera
con paraguay y mientras tanto el
gobierno de francia envió este mismo
viernes un contingente de más de 300
sanitarios a sus departamentos de
guadalupe y martinica en el caribe y
esto para hacer frente a la grave crisis
provocada por la pandemia de coronavirus
que las autoridades vinculan con una
tasa de vacunación muy baja a médicos
enfermeros y también asistentes tomarán
el relevo de otros 240 profesionales que
habían ido la semana pasada a esas dos
islas francesas que tienen sus
hospitales colapsados
turistas y habitantes en países llevarán
una sorpresa a partir del próximo mes y
es que el arco del triunfo va a ser
empacado en papel de regalo continuando
así con el trabajo del artista conocido
como cristo que falleció el año pasado
antes de ver su obra finalizada y su
sobrino está liderando el proyecto que
estaba suspendido debido a la crisis
sanitaria
tuvo la idea hace 60 años pero solo hoy
el sueño del artista christo pudo
volverse realidad empacar el arco del
triunfo con papel de regalo y eso
gracias a su sobrino y a 25 mil metros
de tela
es como mantenerle una promesa es tan
sencillo como eso entonces se lo
prometió si todos lo hicimos
cristo artista búlgaro se dio a conocer
por sus proyectos a escala real ideas
que fueron creadas con su esposa jean
claude la pareja ya en power point of
the paris que en español significa
puente nuevo en
1985 y también el reichstag sede del
parlamento alemán en 1995 diez años
después instaló siete mil hilos de nylon
por todo central park de nueva york el
último proyecto fue financiado gracias a
la venta de anteproyectos y dibujos de
cristo' los trabajadores ya habían
construido andamios para el monumento
del siglo 19 esto para poder acomodar a
la perfección el papel de regalo hecho
de plástico reciclable y para agregar
una cuerda roja que le dará el toque
perfecto exactamente como lo quería el
artista
es pero cristo sería el más feliz que
cuando alguien lo vea diga que se ve
exactamente igual al dibujo
la obra finalizada se podrá visitar a
partir del 18 de septiembre finalizamos
asia otra emisión informativa pero
regresamos el minuto con más noticias
sigan en france 24
[Música]